Bobo's been like calling here every
minute Chrissy's all hopped up they
featured him on the news about car
safety some local oh really
somehow they found him in Orlando and
made him their experts yeah one in
Europe yes a real-time traffic expert
Ryan Harper talked with a man known as
mr. defensive driving known as mr.
defensive driving wow I didn't know that
dude who gave you that name you did
right well they call me that whose name
was in the news the Newsday article did
this is defensive driving but who came
up with me mr. defensive driving the
Newsday editor so no one called you
didn't know they don't call me in the
street that no but I'm saying that like
no one ever named you mr. defensive
driving it was like forget it okay
something they came out without the
Newsday Steve Bowie was once named
2012's national defensive driving
instructor of the year by the National
Safety Council and in his younger years
he received an award for driving 1
million miles for the US Postal Service
without getting into an accident you
know a ton of people have driven without
an accident like my dad is 94 he drove
his whole life never had an accident it
wasn't an opposed no no I was just a
little curious about his million miles
where he did this million miles as the
New York traffic no let me answer your
question 34th and ninth I did Morgan
Street Station Church Street Station and
the guy probably never drove in New York
City traffic I coulda said I did I know
what you said be fine I didn't do it I'm
gonna hook him up to Victorian rather
evaluate him in New York traffic I
actually could listen to this all day I
love when people yell at each other but
I got I got the lie detector thing yeah
called in today is because he wanted to
talk about the polygraph test he says
everybody experimented I think that
means him too
oh you took [ __ ] in your ass I'll come
clean I'm not lying
go ahead it took a mover house central
vacuum yeah I [ __ ] around with that
it's got great suction you to put your
dick in a vacuum hose or you put it up
your ass no special vacuums I had it in
my house you know buddy guys lose their
[ __ ] from that first of all you talk
about safety you're gonna lose your dick
are you out of your mind
and what did you do in your [ __ ] I
stuck that to about my ass but I got a I
got a finger that for a second I'll give
you that well you're like Ronnie you
know you two have something in common
you love mom came to clean the house and
use his smells like [ __ ]
Bobo I mean well you're telling me you
would take a vacuum cleaner like a
central vac right and take the hose and
stick it up your ass yeah you know what
it was how it wasn't that strong like
other ones you know because it's oh of
course it was current on me he almost
like tried it in the front at first it
almost ripped his dick off yeah of
course and it's how many kids lose their
penis because they think they're gonna
[ __ ] the vacuum cleaner and it's not
it's it's the central back for the
housing let me understand this how old
were you when you did this oh and how
long ago yes yeah Wow young I don't know
maybe I was like late twenties yeah
teenager me in your late 20s you were
still in with your mom no without all
right
and then like came to her house to [ __ ]
well good my parents are out [ __ ] their
vacuum why'd you [ __ ] your own bag why
was it beside his news report never had
object what inanimate object everybody
does something like that come on
Oh
[ __ ] I think he's all guilty of sin that
meat is gonna be off the roof but you
know he says that it almost ripped his
dick off so he stuck it represent yeah
camera there's nothing in there you can
rip out that's the bulk of your
intestine
wait a second how far up your [ __ ]
did the vacuum hose go I only did a
couple inches into that thing three
inches so it's probably a two inch
diameter Wow and you got a couple of
inches of your [ __ ] yeah I use the
crevice tool and did you come no
[ __ ]
why do it that was an experiment this is
Thomas Edison you went to visit your
parents in your 20s right so they leave
and as soon as they leave do you scurry
over to the back
not again I suppose doing a few other
things in the house first and then I
make my way over to the vacuum all right
so it's like for place things i thicken
a blend of music and like so you're
imagining like like you're like excited
about the now do you lube up your
[ __ ] I put some Vaseline in all right
so wait a second do you take off all
your clothes
what no no now and how and so does it go
right in or do you have to push it in
kind of slowly response I think he's got
something and then like turn it slowly
and the thing is on right it's the air
is so yeah you said you tried the front
first is that correct yeah the front
first I tried that and try to stick your
dick right put the [ __ ] right away
because that was a little afraid of it
and so you're hard during this right
I've got erectus this foot this thing
doc he looks at a vacuum cleaner and he
gets a rag
soon as I hit it alongside my [ __ ]
that's there then I gotta let you know
big sniff at the end of that because
he's proud wonder what else he's done
and then that was the time that I I blew
the lawnmower Thank You Bobo for being
hot yeah nothing wrong with being honest
hey gotta be honest that's one thing
alone